j'espérais 2h quoi me dire je n'étais
pas là les deux heures ah oui
je ne touche pas de place donc soit leur
envie larmes en nous mais je m'en vais
mais qu'est-ce qui va qu'est ce qui ne
va pas pourquoi silva festive à patins
ne va pas lui va pas le payer il va nous
appeler demain
[Rires]
vallée où je m'habille quoi bon
donc pas tant de postes mais je peux
rester un petit peu
[Applaudissements]
on va passer au 28 mai dernier d'un film
j ai un petit requête parce que tout à
l'heure on est gros quatre familles et
tous étaient vraiment bien et puis bon
on est quand même tous très proches donc
on a besoin de sincérité entre nous et
j'ai quand même l'impression que dans
tout ça vous nous avez caché votre frère
qui est d'ailleurs ici présents dans le
public et je pense qu'il aurait été très
heureux d'être compensées
[Applaudissements]
mon bébé et bien c'est bon non
au bon moment les mêmes à célébrer beau
c'est quoi ton prénom altan
athmane adnane
comment john lannan automne il est comme
moi il est comme moi
[Applaudissements]
9h07 qu'à l'origine mon chéri
pakistanais ah oui c'est vrai si tu
viens du pakistan qu'on nous voie
à des millionnaires aussi
[Rires]
mais toi tu es très bon à cette place
je me coûter très très mauvaise passe
mais si
oui c'est ceux qui sont le plus proche
de la sortie
avant cas d'urgence en cas d' alerte à
san luis gil garden et nature vous êtes
les premiers de ces magnifiques et nyala
c'est comme les issues de secours daniel
on la met là parce que voilà c'est bien
des régions de déplacement